comedy podcasting stats from April Big
Jay oakerson made the most guest
appearances last month going on what has
to be a record-breaking performance 18
total podcasts including are you garbage
take your shoes off The Joe Rogan
Experience this podcast savvy's
world you know what dude whiskey Ginger
the Adam Carolla show two bears one cave
breaking bread with Tom Papa skeptic
tank drinking Bros Howie Mandel about
last night out and about kill Tony and
KFC radio the most viewed episode from
last month was Stavros halcus on this
past weekend with Theo Vaughn that
episode is currently sitting at over 1.9
million views